and now we will hear from those who
suffered indescribably nine years ago
today the following 911 family members I
don't know where you all are I know
you're here uh But Nelly brazinski who
lost her son uh Alex at the age of 38 um
Moren
santura who lost the youngest
firefighter age 23 Christopher
santor um Chief Al santor for 40-year
veteran of the FDNY their daughter
Kathleen a veteran of Iraq and
Afghanistan Rosa leonetti and uh if I'm
calling your name please please come up
I know it's been difficult back here um
and Megan a three and a half year Army
veteran who enlisted when her brother
was slaughtered nine years ago today
Nelly
binski thank you guys I'm happy to see
how many American came it's mean we stay
together like a nine years ago I
remember everybody stayed together it's
wonderful nobody can put us on the knee
I can tell you every everybody asks same
question uh how you feel after 9
years I can tell you secret very
bad every year is bad is more it's worse
because I get older and I feel lonely
and nobody
can bring me back my son I want to ask
Mr Bloomberg because in another way
I have no chance to ask him Mr Bloomberg
tell us please do you sleep well you
don't have a bad
dream nobody talking what we against to
build mask no everybody can build
anything what they want you want to pray
God bless you you want to askk God bless
you but not put mask on the cemetery
because this
place guys guys I don't have many times
because many people behind me I want to
tell you what I want to tell first of
all if you will see on a
cemetery uh place what somebody bury
September 11 it's not a body it's piece
of bone some people bury jacket suit
because they want to have a place to
come in I don't have a place on the
cemetery I just have a park in Israel
have a name Alex binski Park and in the
entrance two uh of course not so big
small one twin
towers and entrance that's it I don't
have a place and this is only one place
and you know special man who is working
man if you will excavate a little
bit one block away two blocks away you
will find bones you will find artifact
of course where is all blood where is
all body everything on the ground and
it's only one place what we can come in
guys believe me what can make a mask a
little bit far from us because we come
and pray we come and visit our people
I'm sorry to say I talk to Muslim now
Muslim in same people but everybody else
you deserve respect
but all people who was on a plane who
killed our 3,000 American was Muslim I'm
sorry it's not Italian not German not
Romanian all of them was Muslim and for
this reason I don't want to came and
pray and moin will pray five times in a
day and yell abbar Allah this same word
they yell when they kill our 3,000 Young
American I'm sure what we will win this
and Mr Bloomberg will think about and I
want to tell just few words to our
president and first lady Mr President
you are the father you have a two
children Michelle abar
you're the mother you have a two kids
try to just imaginate what you see your
child in a fire God forbid and you
cannot help your child tell me what you
will feel I want to know what you will
feel when you see your child in the fire
nobody can help and I believe what God
help us and all of you look at this
million people came it's wonderful thank
you guys
God bless you be
healthy thank you what you coming thanks
a lot but today is day off and you
brought dropped everything to came
support us this is real American
Mr and last word Mr President you are
American you supposed to be Patriot you
supposed to be you want or you don't
want to became a patriot why nobody say
one word in our side everybody say only
about let people pray about freedom of
religion but this is not about freedom
of religion this is about geography you
can pray but a little bit fire what's
big deal God will hear you if you will
pray
thank you
guys thank you God bless you thanks a
lot okay Rosal leonetti
next good afternoon everyone I have a
detail and his name is Fabricio
bonova fabrio was a
paramedic during the 911
if I'm a little emotional today I
apologize well I don't apologize I take
it
back I've cried a lot
today Fabricio step up you
talk good
afternoon like Rosa mentioned I'm a 911
paramedic I lost two of my partners that
day and it really saddens me that we
even have to be here
today I listened to the Imam say he
didn't know the pain this was going to
[Music]
inflict I hear the Imam say he wants to
bridge gaps and bring Muslims and
non-muslims together does that look like
it's happening
[Applause]
I'll give him the benefit of the doubt
maybe he didn't know then but he knows
[Applause]
now there should be no doubt in his mind
when 75 plus perc of the people say
don't do this when family members who've
been victimized are standing out there
and saying please don't do this so the
answer to anyone's question if this
guy's doing this to be provid
provocative or if he's doing it to build
Bridges well we're going to find out
tomorrow if he continues with this
monstrosity or if he stops This Disaster
now so all I'm asking from you is we got
to keep up the fight God bless you let's
honor the Fallen thank
you this morning I gathered with my
family and friends to remember and pay
respects to the
2,976 victims which included my sister's
husband Lieutenant Joseph gullon of
Latter 101 in Red Hook
Brooklyn every year every year fathers
mothers sisters brothers Sons and
Daughters relive the deepest loss and
pain some family members can't bear to
visit the site and so they choose to
honor the memory of a loved one in
private and in
silence we know that strength is born in
the Deep Silence of suffering Hearts not
a Miss jooy we witnessed the strength in
spirit and character it was displayed
proudly nine years ago today when
emergency service Personnel
selflessly sacrificed their lives to
save others
I did not it did not matter to the
411 emergency uh workers what the race
religion nationality or ethnicity of the
men and women and
children were within those Towers it did
not matter to them the passengers on
flight 93 displayed the same strength in
character and today and together they
defeated the radicals whose mission it
was to destroy the White
House we have shown we have much respect
and above all tolerance during these
very long nine years tolerance for the
inept result of the MTA the Lower
Manhattan Development Corporation silver
steam properties and sdl in building a
proper And Timely Memorial site to honor
our loved ones
tolerance we've shown tolerance for a
mayor that now puts his own business
interest in the Middle East ahead of the
longsuffering of family
members many of whom voted for him three
times
tolerance ladies and gentlemen is not
reserved and is not inclusive to just
one religion or one IDE ideology if you
are the leader of this nation and the
Free World then you can't be
inconsistent in tolerating the building
of a mosque under the guise of freedom
of religion and then
admonish a road Pastor who most
Americans disagree with for exercising
his freedom of speech
[Applause]
do not ask us do not ask
me the 911 family members to continue to
tolerate to be tolerant of those who
demonstrate selfish and self-serving
behaviors and
attitudes Iman Abdul rul is quoted us
saying this week that if we don't do
this right moving of the mosque anger
will explode in the Muslim World well
[Music]
imom anger is exploding in America
[Applause]
too he stated he stated that if this
situation is not handled correctly it
could become something very dangerous
indeed does that sound like tolerance to
you
it actually it actually sounds more like
a
threat Mr Ral if I'm mispronouncing it I
apologize but then maybe not Americans
do not like to be
threatened last last I looked up last I
looked up the word tolerance it meant
the fair objective and permissive
attitud ude towards those whose opinions
practices race religion nationality Etc
different from differ from one zone
freedom from bigotry tolerance is not
reserved nor should it be parceled out
to those that use the excuse of building
a cultural center when what they are
erecting is a
robot a robot I'm going to tell you what
this is a robot was typically raised in
the midst of the conquered infidels as a
symbol of triph and
superiority
well not one person that died in those
buildings was an Infidel and not one of
those hijackers was Superior to any FDNY
or
NYPD Mr Abdul rou if you are serious in
your quest to be a BRI Builder and want
to truly showcase your American values
then this is your moment to espouse the
tolerance that you preach to us on a
Continuum if the director of the Cordoba
initiative is correct in his analysis
that this scenario can become bigger
than the Danish cartoon crisis is if
that is indeed the case then you Mr Ro
and your cohorts will own the actions
and the consequences for the Mandate
that you deem necessary to
fulfill as for me as for me and my
patriotic cohorts my tea party people my
Grassroots activists my 911 family
members we will show tolerance indeed
but as Thomas Jefferson stated we will
heed the warning that Eternal vigilance
is the price of Liberty God bless you